So these are gonna be my A level sociology tips
from somebody who got an AI level this year.
So this is probably my biggest piece of advice
that I would give to absolutely
anyone who wants to get an A star this year.
And it is to learn the sociologists and what they do,
because these are such easy
things to put in your 30 markers.
Like, or for any essay question,
you can put a sociologist in there,
and that can be your evidence,
and then you can explain it.
And literally,
it boosts your marks so much,
especially if you do, like,
six paragraphs for a 30 marker,
and you have
a different social address in each one of those,
like Chef's Kiss.
Obviously, if you can't think of one,
don't panic.
But if you can,
try your very best to learn,
then practice writing methods in context,
in timed conditions.
I know everyone hates maths.
In context is literally,
like, the most pointless part of sociology.
I don't even know why it's part of the course,
but it's there,
so unfortunately,
we've got to learn it.
But basically,
you gotta try doing it in time conditions,
because I don't know about you,
but these took up so much of my time when I didn't know,
like, the structure of it or anything like that.
And then basically,
like, once I got them,
like, down pat,
I could literally bite them in about,
like, 20 minutes.
Like, Easy, like
4 marks. It was.
It was good.
So that's why
you need to be able to do it in time conditions,
cause otherwise it will take away from all
the time that you have to write,
like for literally every single other part of your exam.
Okay, if you can't think of evidence,
make it up. Or use things that are going on in the world.
I'm literally not even joking.
So for my methods and context,
I remember I wrote something like,
for example,
if you wanted to use like,
children from the north of English,
English England
or children from like
the south of England,
this would have a different thing
based on their like,
geographical mobility
or something like that.
Or like we did media
and that was really good
cause you could use stuff from like,
the current world.
I remember it was like
media and how that influences,
like, gender.
And I literally use stuff like Weight Watchers,
like Slimming World.
I use like, the dove like,
campaign. Like,
I literally use like,
everything like that.
And you can just use stuff like that.
Like, I'm pretty sure
I wrote about Keeping Up With the Kardashians
and the music video
Blurred Lines
in my actual edible
and it worked
cause it's like,
it's a form of evidence
that literally
socialities all about,
like, the world
and literally
the world around you.
So if you cannot think of anything,
make up. Like,
I'm literally Not joking.
Don't waste your time on the 4 and 6 markers.
I know it can be so easy to open the paper
and be like, oh my god,
I don't know what I'm doing.
But literally,
I think I answered the 4 and 6 markers on like,
my education paper.
I answered them last
because I didn't have a fucking clue
what I was doing with that at all.
So I just did the rest of the paper
and then like,
came back to them
and I ended up getting 75 out of 80
on my education paper.
So the forensics month,
they're not worth
wasting your time over
cause you have so much to do
and you don't have enough time to do it in.
Plan every big question
before you start writing it, basically.
I know this sounds dumb,
I know this sounds stupid
and generic,
but I didn't do this for any of my marks.
I would never plan any of my questions,
and I would end up writing
and then I just write the same thing
and I'd have the same evaluation point.
Like, everything like
that was a huge,
big mess. So then
in my actual A level,
I took the time
and I planned my questions,
like for 10 markers that
everything like that, you know,
and therefore
I could plan
what my point was,
like, what part of the item I would be using,
what evidence I'd use,
and what sociologist I'd
Use with that
then what evaluation point.
I'd be able to use with that as well.
It's just so much easier if you plan it beforehand.
Okay, if you want to put a valuation point,
then just say a perspective
and then say, like,
why they would disagree
or why they would agree with that.
So, for example,
if you're talking about, like,
changing gender roles in the family,
and say if you couldn't
think about
in a valuation point,
basically just be
like, function,
this would disagree with this
because it means that then, like,
nuclear family
is decreasing
or something like that.
And then be like,
this obviously, like,
changing general
affects the nuclear family
because it means that
men on the breadwinner
and women on the housewives,
like things like that
and that she.
Evaluation is so important
that you've actually got to, like,
put evaluation there
if you wanna get good Mark.
So do not neglect evaluation
and don't think
it's just some,
like, easy, like,
thing just slap on the end.
Because, yeah,
you might just put it on the end,
but you've actually gotta,
like, put it on the end
and explain it
if you wanna get the marks
and if you don't wanna get capped
at three out of 10. So top tip.